i had michael rappaport on yesterday
you've been following this whole thing
was rappaport wrong to release the dns
yes yes go ahead leave expand on that oh
come on my
first off i mean who cares number one
number two i mean it's almost like he's
using he's almost like using durant
to up his own thing you know let me go
tell howard that durant's cursed them
yeah so
part of i don't even like that aspect of
it that's the first thing
second thing is why are you getting
involved with durant for now
durant have some issues yeah there's
things about doreen i don't like i hate
the fact he went to golden state when he
left oklahoma city
he took the easy way out i'll be the
first to admit now he's a great player
and he loves to play and i think he's a
good kid but he's too sensitive
and he shouldn't get into an issue with
rapaport but you know you don't you
release that
and make him look bad and get him a
fifty thousand dollar fine and make
durant look like a bad guy well why
would you do that
well the nets win the nba title this
year they have durant they have the team
what is going to be
well first off i don't like the idea
that the nets
brought all these guys in to try to win
an nba championship
harding signed a 155 million dollar
contract and stay with the rockets they
did everything for them they brought
chris paul in
they brought russell westbrook in he
realizes that he can't win
he's got a signed contract now so he
realizes he can't win
so he basically is he shows up at camp
40 pounds overweight
he moans and groans he basically acts
like a jerk to get kicked out of houston
that's not the right thing to do you
made a commitment to the franchise to
ban you 150 million
50 million a year for crown out loud you
don't act like that
and he did and the rockets what are they
going to do they got to trade them they
can't have an unhappy
star so they chamber the nets and then
harden's playing like an mvp
that bothers people a lot of people
don't like that well you don't
would mickey minnow not try to get
traded from the yankees
you don't do that kind of stuff please
why but why can't the knicks
do exactly what the nets did why can't
the knicks go ahead and get
three great players that knicks are the
greatest franchise ever
it used to be prestigious to play in new
york i'll tell you why they can't do it
because they have not yet been able to
recruit
a star and the nba's big
problem right now is the stars want to
play with the stars
anthony davis wants to play with lebron
durant wants to play with kyrie irving
the great player wants to win and he
wants to play with his buddy who's also
a great player
and the knicks don't have any great
players so if durant says okay now can i
go to the nets
when i have kyrie irving and i got a
chance to win
or do i go play for the knicks we stink
i
can't win the media will give me a hard
time if we don't win
the hell with it do you think durant
wants does durant want to be on a team
that goes 40 and 42 and 40
and gets knocked out in the first half
of the playoffs or does durant want to
go
eight miles away to barclay center and
play with kyrie irving
and they can win a championship and he
can do his thing in in solitude
so he takes the easy way that goes to
the mets that's the reason why the
knicks can't they can't get a big star
to take their money